Another great way of getting data in data science
is by scraping data. This is important because not
all data comes in nice JSON formats. Not all
data is built for access and so sometimes you
have to get creative in how you access the data.
For instance, I can include HTML text on a web
page or tables on Wikipedia or PDF documents or
media like images and video and audio and so on.
Also, there's Word documents and there's
PowerPoint presentations, and any number
of sources that have data that do not come in
a nice package for importing into Python or R.
Be aware of issues of copyright and
confidentiality. This data was not created
for you to scrape and sometimes there are reasons
why it's been restricted. You need to be aware
of what the restrictions are and to respect those
and operate professionally. If you want to scrape
data, you have a couple of choices. One is use
readymade tools. For instance, import.io. That's
both a web address and it's the name of a tool
that makes scraping data from web pages very easy.
ScraperWiki and Tabula also make this easy.
In fact, in Google Sheets you can simply use
the =IMPORTHTML_ command to pull data out of
a table and even some versions of Excel make
this possible. Or, you can use custom tools. You
can scrape data through R, Python, Java, or PHP.
Any of these will make it possible for
you to access data and manipulate it in
the ways that you need to get
it in to an analyzable format.
In conclusion, scraping works when APIs don't
exist for the data that you want to work with.
Also, you can use specialized apps that
were created for scraping or you can
code in your language of choice. Finally,
copyright and confidentiality issues matter
and they should always be considered carefully
before you start scraping data off the web.